Bonjour les abonnés YouTube
Ouais ça avance tout seul, ça s'appelle un escalator plat
Première anecdote on arrive a l'aéroport 1h30 en avance et malgré tout qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
On rate l'avion !!
Le problème avec mon casque de gros geek, c'est que quand je le mets on dirait que je fais une vidéo de gaming
Yo! Tout le monde c'est Squeezie ! On se retrouve pour une nouvelle vidéo complètement déjantée sur un jeu japonais
Bah ! Ben alors je suis coincé !
LOL !
Je suis arrivé niveau 8 !!
On s'en bat les steaks !
Allez Ciao !
Norman et John, je vous fait parvenir ce missiv ... message
Accepteriez vous une photo ?
Message écrit sur un sac à vomi
On a retrouvé le fameux Thomas qui a laissé un p'tit mot dans l'avion. *bruit de photos*
Bon séjour Thomas
Ah, il a dit baise bien. Il est coquin ce Thomas !
On peut clairement dire que dans ton plat, quelqu'un a mis du shampooing
*rire de Jhon*
Jhon : Fructis évolution
*Rire de Norman*
Bonjour. Et quelqu'un rentre dans ma chambre
C'est faux
J'ai complétement entendu des voix
je suis Jeanne d'Arc et
John Rachid c'est totalement endormi euh sur le canapé
en glace. Cet homme peut dormir
Vraiment n'importe où quoi. Là on est à Andorre
Qui est une petite ville
Jhon : principauté
en Espagne. On est sur un petit Vlog
un vlog c'est quoi c'est un vidéo blog
Jhon : Un vidéo blog, tu lis plus vite ça fait vlog
Ouais tu mélanges deux mots, ça fait un seul mot
Jhon : Parce qu'un mot plus un mot
ça fait un mot. On a pas le temps on prend de la neige
Mmmhhhh on fait n'importe quoi avec
*rire de Norman*
attends, j'm'en suis rentré dans le nez
Y'a un gros débat pour savoir qu'est-ce qu'il y a de mieux entre snowboard et patinette
Hein les petites snowblades
Jhon : moi je vais vous dire la vérité
Je prends des snowblades parce que ça va beaucoup plus vite
Et je prends plus de plaisir qu'en snowboard
Regarde le mec qu'il y'a ici c'est quoi est-ce que c'es un snowblade?
Non ! C'est le snowboard
Jhon : Oui mais
Tu feras jamais ça
Norman : Style au max
Ce mec va faire des patinettes
ça va être extremement nul
Ouhh regardez il est tout seul
On est sur le télé-siège avec Titouche
Titouche : Salut
Et histoire énorme, y'avait un mec ici installé
Avec nous et bah cet homme
Est tombé du télé-siège sans problème
Il a continué en ski
Euh tout seul *haha*
Hey Michel !!
J'vois son bâton
Le mec espagnol : Jordi, catalan
Norman : Jordi, catalan, si euh....
la paella
Oh lala je suis cabossé mon gars
Alors là on carrément face à un bouchon
On est face à un très très gros bouchon
Et le tire-fesses ça pose de problèmes à personne
Moi c'est bon tant qu'il y'a le mot fesses dedans ça me va
Le principe de l'espagnol c'est que c'est une langue que tu peux parler que très fort
ça fait 15min qu'elle parle comme ça
*dame qui parle espagnol vite et fortement*
Un vrai plaisir
Voilà ma coupe de cheveux après 3h de snow
Complètement défoncée
voix féminine : C'est exactement comme d'habitude en fait
Cet homme est Bob Marley en réincarné
-Merci mon pote
-De rien à plus les gars j'espère que vous vous êtes bien amusés
Un vrai plaisir de glisse surtout le moment
Où j'avais la tête dans le sol, dans la neige ça j'ai vraiment kiffé
OH  MY  GOD
On se prend une vraie claque de paysages
C'est bizarre de voir des publicités pour le tabac
Les gens te disent vraiment "Fumes beaucoup c'est vraiment très très bien
A Andorre, ils se prennent pas la tête, ils font carrément le pack bouteille de 'sky double cartouches, pour se déchirer la gueule
Le pack pochtron
Le kit du bon saoulard
J'ai trouvé mieux, aucun rapport ils font carrément
Donc le pack doubles cartouches de camel avec un bras à selfie
Ces deux objets n'ont aucun rapport
ça n'a aucun sens ce pack
Ils m'ont mis deux poissons panés
Je suis hyper content rien que pour ça
Je suis clairement hyper content les gars
Musique : What do you mean ?
je suis dans la voiture avec mes sab
et là qu'est ce que je vais faire
de l'helicoptère
moi j'ai un peu peur aussi je t'avoue que ça commence à chocotte la hein
ça commence clairement à chocotte hein expression des année 70
OK!!! le stress est maximal aaaah!!!
J'ai très très peur
OK on est partis les gars je suis dans l'helico
*musique épique*
heureusement que l'on a une ceinture de sécurité au cas où
j'ai totalement l'impression d'être dans la carte au trésor
*nouvelle musique épique*
on est en train d’atterrir
on as atterit
on l'a fait les gars
Gracias amigo, gracias !
j'ai vaincu une phobie là
je sais pas si vous vous en rendez compte
Jhon : et bah bravo *applaudit*
non franchement ça fait 28 ans je flippe de monter dans un hélico
pourtant c'est mon gros rêve
Jhon : T'as pas vaincu la phobie du cadrage par contre
*rire de Norman*
Pour apprendre à bien manger avec des baguettes
très très simple, je vous montre ou pas ?
tu fais comme ça, tu prends les baguettes
tu les mets ici et tu prends vraiment la fourchette
*rire*
voila, très simple
j'explique aux gens le jeu ridicule de gamin que tu fais ?
Jhon : bah vas-y
dès que je mets mes écouteurs, ils disent des conneries sur moi
Jhon : non, non
l'autre : on dit que des vérités
Jhon : j'ai 21 ans, je vais pas faire ça
l'autre : il a tellement le vieux style en plus
Jhon : avec ces vieux cheveux, il croit que ça fait stylé !
coupe tes veuch frère !
l'autre : aucun rythme !
*rire*
*musique cool de gangsta'*
bienvenue dans Automoto
aujourd'hui on teste quoi ?
l'autre : la moto-neige
c'est un beau modèle chelou qui a la patate
l'autre : non non, rien n'a envier aux autres concurrents
c'est plus crevant d'être derrière que devant et c'est pas de tout repos
hey... j'ai perdu 2 vertèbres
c'est génial, je vais devoir aller chez le kiné, (et chez le coiffeur...)
mais sinon, c'est bien
ça fait quoi quand tu jettes une Go-Pro en l'air
aujourd'hui je vais réaliser l'un de mes rêves que j'ai envie de faire depuis que je suis vraiment tout petit
du chien de traîneau
ils font un peu bader, mais ils sont supers mignons
on dirait qu'ils vont me sauter dessus
*chiens aboient*
c'est des chiens de traineaux qui ont vraiment un style de doberman de tess
*musique de gangsta'*
le danger est total, ces chiens sont des putains de chiens d'attaque
*aboie*
oh non, ils font de la peine un peu
lui je l'aime bien lui, lui c'est mon pote, comment ill s'appelle ?
femme : Aquila
Norman : Aquila
j'arrive pas à le dire
femme : tu veux lui faire un bisou ?
Norman :  euh...  je lui ferais pas un bisou
*rire de la femme*
vraiment je préfère largement une petite poignée de main bien virile, une petite caresse entre ami
femme : tu sais jusqu'à combien ils peuvent survivre ?
Norman : non
femme : -40°
Norman : -40° !!
Norman : sérieux ?!
donc rassurez-vous, les chiens sont totalement en bonne condition, ils ont pas froid du tout
contrairement à ce que je pensais
*bisou*
j'ai totalement peur
*rire*
ouuuh, on est parti, on est tiré par les putains de chien !!!
aller les toutous !!
wouah ! oh là on prend une descente mon gars !
oh mes doigts sont des MisterFreeze
le mec : tiens prends ça
Norman : le mec me donne UN gant
vous avez pas l'odeur, mais y'a vraiment une bonne odeur de bons chiens
j'ai l'impression d'être dans une putain de niche
une, dos, tres.... viva les caninos !
j'aurais jamais cru être aussi proche de toi pendant un moment aussi incroyable
l'autre : j'avoue que c'est pas pour me déplaire
*rire*
Oklm les chiens, OKLM !
j'espère que vous avez apprécié ce petit Vlog, cette petite vidéo, ce petit bonus, appelez-le comme vous voulez
en tout cas, nous on s'est bien marrer à la faire
Jhon : nous on a kiffé à le faire, de vous présenter nos vacances, on s'est éclaté avec vous
abonnez-vous à ma chaîne Youtube et à la sienne, Jhon Rachid
Jhon : et à la mienne beaucoup, beaucoup
à très très bientôt, ciao !!
Jhon : SALUT !